it is my pleasure to welcome James Lowen
today to discuss his new book which is
called sundown towns dr. Lowen is also
the author of the best-selling book lies
my teacher told taught me which is loved
by teachers and students alike because
it takes aim at the sanitized textbooks
used to misrepresent history his new
book sundown towns is the result of
years of research into the formation and
the persistence of white-only towns I've
often wondered about towns with names
like Whitesboro or White City but the
story of codified white supremacy in
American towns and suburbs is long and
harrowing and amazingly well hidden this
book is a remarkable contribution to the
account of institutionalized racism in
the United States I'm glad to note that
the book is reviewed very favorably by
Laura Wexler in today's Washington Post
please welcome dr. James Lowen thanks
Virginia thanks to all of you for coming
out I want to say just a word about
independent bookstores in general and
this one in particular I've actually
become an educated person by coming to
all these free events here and I want to
thank you all at the bookstore for them
and I want to also say that I do make it
my policy usually I try to when I come
to a free event like this book talk to
buy a book not necessarily the book
that's being sold that evening but some
book before leaving because although
it's a free event the bookstore still
needs to make money somehow you know
this evening however I would suggest
that you would want to get my book
you were supposed to laugh just when I
said this evening however you're not as
sharp as I was hoping but anyway um I
also want to say something about this
book just to get started um I actually
think it's the most important book I've
written and I've written seven maybe I
don't know maybe eight um
lies my teacher told me has done awfully
well and it keeps on selling and I'm
very happy I voted and I think it's a
very important book but lies my teacher
told me makes people amazed who are not
historians or haven't really studied it
closely actually even amazes historians
out of their period but any historian
who knows about for instance the Civil
War and reads what I say about it in
lies my teacher told me is not amazed
okay but this book sundown towns is
actually going to I think amazed
everyone sociologists and historians and
so on because in it I think I have
discovered and and published for the
world a bunch of new stuff stuff that's
never been written by anybody before and
I think it's actually disgusting as well
as amazing that it's never been written
by anybody before in fact while I was
doing the research for this book which
took me five five years of doing almost
nothing else I kept expecting to find
stuff about this subject and and I found
virtually nothing at all okay so I want
to take you all on a journey of
discovery because I have to persuade you
of the magnitude of the phenomenon that
sundown towns purports and I think
correctly purports to have discovered
all right and if I just tell it to you
I'm not sure you'll believe me because I
didn't believe it I had you know I had
to find it I had to be convinced of it
so I want to take you on the same
journey that I made um and the process
of taking that journey we're going to
answer the basic questions which are
what also on downtown's where are they
how many are there when did they get
created um how did they get created how
do they get maintained what image do
they make anyway and finally what should
we do about them well what is the Sun
downtown a Sun downtown is a community
that for decades and some of them still
do it kept out people of color
particularly after african-americans now
some of them kept out especially in the
West Chinese Americans or Japanese
Americans I discovered two towns in
Nevada that sounded a whistle at 6:00
p.m. every night to tell Native
Americans or American Indians they must
be gone I discovered one town in
California and one in Colorado and I'm
sure I've missed probably dozens more
that kept out Mexican Americans there
are many many many suburbs especially
and also some beach communities and some
resort mountain communities that kept
out Jewish Americans okay and all of
those things are covered in some
downtown's but the great target was and
to some degree remains african-americans
okay oh they get their title because
many of these towns in the Midwest in
Oregon in California in the across the
North except the Northeast and the East
um put signs at their City Limits
typically saying quote [ __ ] don't let
the Sun go down on you in Manitowoc for
instance which is a town a city actually
of about 30,000 in Wisconsin on Lake
Michigan and which did have such science
or I might have said Ashland Oregon or
Taft California or Pekin Illinois or
Miaka
City Florida all of which did have
subsides okay not all sundown towns had
such signs of course um many of them did
not almost know sundown suburbs had such
signs and I need to tell you that
sundown well let's get the skip ahead to
when did these towns come into being
they came into being between 1890 and
1940 for the most part there's some
seats in the middle here the couple over
here they came into being between 1890
and 1940 they weren't always this way
one of the things I learned while doing
the research for this book is that in
America between 1862
and 1890 african-americans went
everywhere all right
they got into every county in Indiana
but one every county in Montana but one
all over the place okay Chinese
Americans did the same thing
this actually surprised me even more I
mean of course I grew up in and until
recently kind of thought of Chinese
Americans as creatures of the big city
they live in Chinatown in San Francisco
do they not Chinatown in this city
Chinatown in Chicago and so on well yes
they do now I thought this was just
natural of course when the sociologist
says natural he puts quotation marks
around it by which he really means deep
in our culture so that I didn't think
about it all right um after all they had
left a big city most Chinese came here
from Canton China over 90% that's a big
city they came on ocean-going vessels of
course and they mostly came into a big
city San Francisco the largest city in
the West at the time but no that's not
the case they came into San Francisco
and they went all over the place they
were in every county in Wyoming they
were in 1890 well excuse me in 1870 and
into the 1880s they were in every county
of Idaho in fact they were 20% of the
population of Idaho which is one of our
most rural States than n-now okay but
then between about 1884 and 1900 the
Chinese undergo a vast retreat and it's
kind of a prologue to what I'm going to
talk about happened to black folks that
is they get pressured out of in fact
they get driven out of every county in
Wyoming except one they get driven out
of almost every county and community in
Idaho more than 50 towns in California
drive out their Chinese even large
cities like Tacoma Washington drive out
the entire Chinese population send them
on to big boats back to San Francisco so
that's how Chinese ended up in Chinatown
okay well I had the same misconception
about African Americans I grew up in
Decatur Illinois which is a city of
sixty to ninety thousand depending on
which census you look at in the center
of Illinois and it had a substantial
block black population about 15 20
percent I knew that and I never occurred
to me that all the little towns around
Decatur Monticello Niantic
doulton city should these names mean a
lot to you I knew they were all white it
never occurred to me they were all white
on purpose I mean I thought I'd rather
live in Decatur it has motion picture
theaters you know and and grocery stores
and things and and that's what black
folks would rather do I'll tell you
about how my mind got changed in in just
a few minutes so between 1863 and when
refugees from the Civil War and when
thing in slavery basically started
ending everywhere the United States Army
controlled between 1863 and 1890 black
folks went everywhere I mentioned they
ended up in every county in Indiana but
one every county of Montana but one and
so on then beginning in 1890 from 1890
to 1940 commenced what historians call
the nadir of race relations and a nadir
of course means low point right it's an
english-language word we're not talking
valve here and a dir um the opposite of
Zenith I guess the nadir of race
relations is the period 1890 to 1940 I
have a whole chapter on it in here in
which I call it the nadir gestation I
don't know what I call it something like
the nadir gestation period for sundown
towns what happened during the nadir was
in the South uh the real end of
Reconstruction now of course
reconstruction formally ended in about
1876 but it black folks are still voting
in the south there were still
possibility for black-white coalition's
the the Democratic Party had no lock on
the south at that point of course
remember the Democrats were the party of
white supremacy in the 19th century and
well into the 20th century into the
1920s called themselves the white man's
party this is hard to remember sometimes
because exactly 41 years ago the two
parties flip-flopped on this matter but
in the 19th century the Democrats were
the party of white supremacy and they
ended reconstruction by force and fraud
in 1876 but they didn't really end the
voting of black folks they didn't really
end the possibility for interracial
cooperation in the south that ended in
1890 with Mississippi's
tune of 1890 which removed blacks from
citizenship took away the right their
right to vote and the United States did
nothing even though it directly
contravenes the 14th and 15th amendments
to the Constitution so ever the other
southern state and states as far away as
Oklahoma followed suit by 1907 okay
that's one of the reasons we date the
Nader exactly at 1890 there are a couple
of others but I won't go into a mine now
but what I've learned doing this
research is that the period of
reconstruction while it only applied
legally to the south it applied
ideologically to the whole country
that and actually nobody's written about
that either or hardly anybody in the
North especially in Republican
communities or communities with
considerable numbers of Quakers or
Unitarians or Presbyterians or United
States or Chrysler Congregationalists or
Methodists and these are a lot of
communities you know these towns
actually many of them developed a
welcoming attitude towards black folks
let me give you just one example Fond du
Lac Wisconsin even during the Civil War
I think was in late 1863 or early 64 a
train comes to Fond du Lac bearing one
or two cars passenger cars full of black
folks along with a white chaplain from
the United States Army who had been
assigned to Cairo Illinois which is down
at the bottom of Illinois where which
was kind of a staging ground for the
civil war in the Mississippi Valley and
a bunch of refugees black refugees and
white luigi's for that matter and wound
up in Carroll so he helped this carload
or so get to Fond du Lac and it was
their biggest event in town everybody
comes down to see these folks and
haven't been very many black folks in
Wisconsin at that point and folks sign
up for them I could use a hand I'm
putting in a new orchard I could use too
you know and so on before they got
parceled out to folks they all got
supper and spent the night in the local
hotel downtown
and then the next day they they went off
and commenced living in Fond du Lac okay
and so it was kind of I think it was
kind of like and not just in Fond du Lac
the phenomenon that we saw in the 1960s
and early 1970s when colleges actually
across the north
and the South started competing for our
african-americans I mean my college for
instance Carlton college I actually went
to college with the fifth black person
ever to graduate from Carleton College
and Carlton had been in existence 102
years when I graduated so that you can
do the math that's one every 21 years or
so okay um but I graduated in 1964 right
at that point Carleton and Yale and
University of Maryland for that man
started competing in the late 60s for
African Americans and certainly opening
up their gates to them and I think many
many towns especially Republican towns
opened up to black folks across the
north but then in the 1890s now 1890 to
1940 this nadir this reaction this
terrible period sets in another reason
we dated to 1890 is because in 1890 the
United States Senate failed to pass by a
single vote the fair elections bill now
this bill is kind of similar to the 1965
Voting Rights Act not as good but not a
bad bill it would have helped publicize
the fact that blacks were increasingly
finding it difficult to vote fairly and
freely in the south it would have
penalized the south for interfering with
black right away anybody's right to vote
and so on and it passed the House and it
failed by a single vote in the Senate of
course president Benjamin Harrison a
Republican president would have signed
it into law
well after defeating this bill the
Democrats did the usual trick which was
to tar the Republicans to accuse them of
being quote black Republicans unquote of
being nothing but a bunch of quote
[ __ ] lovers unquote the Republicans
had faced this before what they had done
up until then was to say you're darn
right somebody ought to be standing up
for these folks it's an outrage what you
people are doing down the south on
election day and this needs to stop but
they made a new response after 1890 the
new response was no react and you
remember what the charge was no we
aren't so at that point the Republicans
gave up on civil rights for everybody
and that's another reason then we ended
Democrats had never had an use for it at
all so now there was no political or or
any remedy for the the left quality of
African Americans and African
American civil rights in America well
across the United States then between
1890 and 1940 as I discovered in doing
the research for sundown towns community
after community drove out its black
population and I've uncovered scores of
little race riots we know we've always
known of a few of the big ones
like I think was 1917 East st. Louis
1919 Chicago 1919 Washington DC only
recently has the memory of the one in
Tulsa Oklahoma I think 1921 then we
covered we know of that one now but I'm
talking about scores more the race riot
in Pinckneyville Illinois for instance
which I haven't even dated for sure but
I think was 1928 in which the black
community was expelled never to return
and it's an eerie sense that you have
I've been in the community in
Pinckneyville called the Black Hills now
I got to tell you it's not called the
Black Hills because it looks like South
Dakota okay it is hilly mildly hilly I
mean we're talking Illinois after all
it's called the Black Hills because this
was the black community since 1928 it
has been all white okay and in sundown
towns there's a portfolio of pictures in
here which I recommend to you those of
you with the book frankly no it's
alright I recommend the pictures because
they will help take you through this
process of discovery about this topic
that otherwise is I hope new to you
because it was certainly new to me
now if you've known this all along come
up and tell me doing this book signing
and I'll learn from you some of the
things you know but in the portfolio of
pictures for instance there's a photo of
the black school in pink evil which
since 1928 has been a white house okay
now I don't know if the black residence
of Pinckneyville got paid for these
houses I do know they did not get paid
market value because of course they fled
in a night of terror and it's real hard
to negotiate a fair price under that
condition okay and in many towns for
instance Pierce City Missouri which had
its riot a little earlier 1901 and 1902
and there's a picture here of one of the
houses in push that he had over 300
black folk
10% of the population drove them out in
a fiery night burn some of the houses
the other houses just got taken and God
lived in by white folks blacks didn't
get a dime for this this is just like
what happened in Nazi Germany in 1937 38
ok and this happened in town after town
most recently and I think this is just
amazing
most recently in 1954 in Vienna Illinois
when the black community was torched out
never to return and nothing was done
about it well I first learned of these
the first of these towns that I learned
about while I was in undergraduate
maybe I mentioned I went to Carleton
College in southern Minnesota Carleton
back then had a bunch of people it has
fewer now but had a bunch of people from
Minnesota going to it you know and many
of those were from the suburbs of
Minneapolis st. Paul and some of them
were from the richest single suburb and
most prestigious single suburb which was
he and still is Edina and the folks from
Edina said some of them with pleasure
some of them were chagrin that a Dinah
was known far and wide for having quote
not one Negro and not one Jew and it
didn't either but just for the record
since then it now does it has one of
each oh no it has a bunch but then it
had one nun and I thought that was
outrageous
actually and then I learned a little
later of the notorious Darien
Connecticut which is one of the richest
and most prestigious suburbs of New York
City and Darien was briefly famous for
this practice in 1948 the Academy Award
winning Best Picture went to gentleman's
agreement uh which uh trying to remember
the star Gregory Peck thank you um which
is a movie about the fact that Realtors
and the power structure in general in
Darien Connecticut had a gentlemen's
agreement to keep out choose and of
course keep out african-americans
incidentally the movie didn't do any
good locally that is to say Gary and
maintained the policy for several more
decades after 1948 but still
it became kind of locally famous that
you're supposed to be an Aryan if you
live in Darien oh I thought that was our
ages and then I learned of Anna Illinois
Anna is a town down back here Oh 30
miles north of Cairo and I learned that
in 1909 Carroll had a spectacle lynching
you know lynchings became spectacle
lynchings around 1900 some of them did
and this was one of those by this I mean
it was announced ahead of time so it's a
long story how this lynching happened
and what the sheriff was doing and so on
it's all told him in sundown towns it
was perhaps the first brilliantly
illuminated nighttime lynching in the
United States there's a photo of it in
the book a double overhead arch of
lights
Carroll was very proud of this
illuminated Carol's downtown major
intersection and this is where they had
this nighttime lynching thousands of
people came and they're all in the photo
the the Illinois Central ran excursion
trains to make a buck to kill come see
this famous event and a bunch of people
came from Anna Illinois 30 miles to the
north partly because the woman who had
been murdered allegedly by the black man
who was about to be lynched hailed from
Anna originally and ironically was named
Anna well after she was killed and after
he the alleged assailant was hung in the
in downtown Cairo the folks from Anna
went home and thought that was such a
good idea that they drove out there
black population and from that day to
this Anna has been known as quote ain't
no [ __ ] allowed a nna unquote and
again I just thought that was outrageous
and so I vowed finally to write a book
about it and I'm actually sorry that I
didn't write it years ago but but I've
written it now well where are these
towns person after person has told me
when I said well I'm writing it you know
they said what are you doing now you
know you've got lies my teacher told
told me is done and lies across America
and I said well I'm working on this book
on Sunday on town towns
kept out black folks they say oh yeah
down in Mississippi right Alabama no are
the traditional South didn't do this
this is a phenomenon across the north
but generally not in the traditional
south now it is in the what we might
call the non-traditional sounds like the
Ozarks if you consider that south or
Appalachia far Western North Carolina
Far East Tennessee for instance far west
Maryland but Mississippi for instance I
lived in Mississippi for seven or eight
years so I did an exhaustive search of
sundown towns in Mississippi I believe I
located six okay how many have I found
in the rest of the country well I grew
up in Illinois so I decided I would do
more research in Illinois than any other
single place setting single state partly
because if somebody said well I've heard
that Kenilworth is at some downtown well
I knew that was a suburb of Chicago were
somebody says I've heard that Villa
Grove had a Simon which we'll get to
Villa Grove siren in a minute I would
know that that was kind of an Eastern
Illinois I expected to find 10 sundown
towns in Illinois and maybe 50 across
the rest of the country I found 472
sundown towns in Illinois alone which
translates to probably 10,000 across the
United States okay this is a majority of
all incorporated communities in Illinois
all right now this is astounding and and
I wouldn't blame you if you if you don't
believe me in fact I want to recount a
brief conversation I had with some folks
in Wisconsin about this I asked these
folks one guy in particular who's a fine
scholar expert on is a historian he
works at the Wisconsin State Historical
Society he's the expert in the US on the
black press on african-american
newspapers across the country I asked
him if he knew of any sundown towns in
Wisconsin and he replied by email
something like this no you may find a
few of these communities in Illinois but
I've asked several of my colleagues here
at the Wisconsin State Historical
Society and we don't believe there are
any in Wisconsin okay well I believe
that there are at least 200 in Wisconsin
and I have found and proven at least 10
okay um now you might say 10 out of 200
that's not very good is it well no I
didn't do that much research in
Wisconsin on the ground I think that
they that they will prove to be so um
but my correspondent when I brought to
him that I had 10 including large cities
major towns like already mentioned
Manitowoc Appleton Appleton Wisconsin is
a city of 50,000 over 70,000 people
depending on which census you look at
and everybody in Appleton knew it to be
a sundown town as recently as the early
1970s this is where Lawrence University
is this is where a certain man named Joe
McCarthy comes from um he was amazed
folks in Wisconsin were amazed ok so how
can I convince you that this actually
happened but I want to tell you the
moment that I really it was kind of an
aha moment when I realized that I had
been miss thinking this see I've been
putting all white communities into three
categories first your son downtown's
like Anna second your son down suburbs I
need to tell you they're a little in
later if Sunday on towns are 1892 1940
that's when they were created sunday on
suburbs are about 1905 or so to 1968
some of them even later but they mostly
still still being created as of 1968 but
the largest category I thought would be
all white towns that are all white by
accident that is towns that no black
folks ever went to like these little
towns around Decatur I thought why do
black folks have to go to every dumb
little town that I didn't want to live
in anyway you know okay all white by
accident so that was my residual
category I still always put a community
there it's a community of interest to me
but I put it there until proven
otherwise right then one evening I
remember it vividly it was October 2001
I was speaking at my hometown the
Decatur Public Library I was the keynote
speaker at the second annual Decatur
writers
conference this is because I'm the third
best-selling author from Decatur for the
first annual one they had had the
best-selling author for the second
annual one they had me the third
best-selling author I asked him how come
they didn't have the second best-selling
author who is who was Stephen Ambrose
the famous historian he was then alive
and furthermore was before his
plagiarism scandal and and they said
well that's a good question he said
because he charges forty thousand
dollars plus a private jet both ways and
I said gee I say drover $38,000 and he
said yes yes you did so I was speaking
at the second annual Decatur Writers
Conference and I gave my talk about lies
my teacher told me I was going to waive
it but it seems to have moved away um
and after I got done I said well now I'm
doing this research on some downtown's
and I told him what to send downtown was
and I asked them to come on down if they
knew anything about it to my amazement
20 people came down and I had my little
yellow pad and you can see I've got my
yellow paper here and I'm going to have
it at my book signing and if any of you
know about some sympathy on towns that I
may have missed please tell me and I'll
write down your email and what you know
and so on we'll get some more
information because I want to out every
one of them but anyway they all came
down these 20 people and they told me
that town after town around Decatur that
they understood the following about it
for instance Niantic little town of 900
just northwest of Decatur even touches
Decatur on its northwest corner
not exactly a suburb if there was an
independent town to different people
told me that they understood that
Niantic had in ordinance said black
folks could not spend the night and that
as a result of this ordinance the Wabash
railroad you for the Wabash Cannonball
it went past my house it actually was a
train and it went through Decatur and
the biggest yard of the Wabash is
indicated with such a big yard it spills
into Niantic and they told me that the
Wabash railroad every night had to move
its work train from the Niantic part of
the ID to the Decatur part of the ID to
avoid offending this ordinance because
you know people sleep on the work train
and some of them are african-american
and so they had to move this train well
I confirmed later with two different old
ex employees of the Wabash that was
indeed the case two different people
told me that
Villa Grove Illinois which is a town
over by Champaign Urbana where
University of Illinois is the villa
Grove blew a whistle every night at 6:00
p.m. to tell blacks to be out of town
now I thought this was preposterous I
didn't know if you could have an urban
legend in a town of 2,500 but I thought
it was an urban legend okay now what's
telling me two things was it not number
one Villa Grove has a whistle and number
two Villa Grover's probably a Sun
downtown at least these two people
thought it was and had heard that it was
but the idea that it blew a whistle at
6:00 p.m. I mean Villa Grove is not on
the way to anywhere and and you know I'm
thinking either a whole bunch of African
Americans at the edge of town at 5:59
only to be downcast once again because
this damn whistle goes off you know why
not have a whistle to keep the elephants
out you know I thought it was
preposterous so then but you know I vote
it down and about a year later I made a
point to visit Villa Grove and in fact I
visited Villa Grove in the late
afternoon on a Saturday 4:30 p.m. I went
to the shangri-la hotel and I recommend
the next time you find yourself in Villa
Grove in the evening that you stay at
the other one um the shangri-la is
mostly an SLO single room occupancy for
old white men and I thought I would go
interview some of these old white men
because they know stuff you know they
know I'm not just about their their past
in Villa Grove someone might be from
other towns and they could tell me all
kinds of stuff you have to do this
research through oral history stuff
isn't written down generally there are
exceptions but generally it's not
written down I'll come back to that in
just a minute on my way up the stairs to
the shangri-la I was accosted lightly
enough by the weekend manager who was
sitting on the porch and he said can I
help you and I want to recount for you
this conversation verbatim I think I
haven't memorized
I certainly voted down right afterwards
I said sure and I said something like ah
my name is Jim Lowen which just for the
record it is and I'm from Decatur over
here you know I legitimize myself by
talking about where I'm fund everything
and I said is it true that Villa Grove
has or had until
recently because my informants weren't
sure if it if it still sounded but it
Villa Grove has or head until recently a
simon whistle that sounds at 6:00 p.m.
and he says yes I said well is it on a
factory or a grain elevator so I figured
it was probably a shift change at a
factory he said oh no it's on the water
tower city property isn't it so then I
said well why did it I said does it
still sound he said no stopped about
three years ago I had this conversation
in October of 2002 so this would have
been 1999 when it stopped I said well
what did it sound for why did it go off
and he said quote well um do you mean um
originally and I said yes originally and
he said well um eventually um and I said
to myself my god it's true and so I said
to him four words no content I didn't
want to influence what he was going to
say but I said these four words it's
okay
I know hi and he looked relieved and he
said well originally it sounded to tell
black folks to be out of town and I was
so this isn't good interviewing I pride
myself as being a good interviewer but I
was so surprised even though I was
understanding it happening I said to him
really and he said yes and I said well
why did they stop it was it because
Villa Grove changed its policy and he
didn't know whether they'll go over
changed its policy or not but he said no
they it's got stopped because people who
live near the water tower got tired of
the noise okay now to be sure for many
people in Villa Grove over the years it
became the six o'clock whistle all right
now jr. you better be home at six
o'clock for supper when you hear that
whistle go off there's no doubt that's
the main meaning of it but I asked him I
said do you mean to tell me that people
as late as 1998-99 we're still learning
the original meaning of the whistle and
he said oh yes okay he proceeded to tell
me all kinds of other things about which
mayor's administration it still sounded
through when it stops sounding and so on
I spent next Monday I went back
Villa Grove on Monday and I spent most
of Monday interviewing other people
everything he told me proved to be true
I confirmed it with at least seven other
people all right I'm going to close this
talk with my final interview in Villa
Grove but we'll come back I'm not ready
to close quite yet okay um so I became
aware that this null category this this
category of towns that were all-white by
accident was vanishingly small
they almost every town that was
all-white for census after census was
all white on purpose even if it was in
the Upper Peninsula of Michigan even if
it was in Idaho and for sure if it was
in Illinois or Maryland or whatever and
not just because of that one evening but
but that was the line of thinking I went
through um what else do I need to tell
you how was this maintained well by all
manner of basically of white male
behavior bad behavior by white folks
okay I already mentioned the Wyatts by
which these all-white towns were created
many other towns like Villa Grove
well Villa Grove may have driven out its
black population I don't know but if it
didn't ever have one then it probably
and it Villa Grove has a strong oral
tradition of having passed an ordinance
okay and in a sense it has a visible
representation of an ordinance so it's
hard to show you an ordinance visibly
but I show this whistle because he's
still on the water tower I took a
picture of it and put it in the book
it's a visual visible manifestation of
the ordinance because it was put up by
the county by the community excuse me to
symbolize the and to sound off
the policy since then I found seven
towns in all that had a six pm whistle
and six of them was for this reason
including these two in Nevada that I
mentioned earlier that the whistle was
to keep out Native Americans other towns
are in Michigan and Ohio and and other
places in the United States
often it was maintained in suburbs by
government policies like the zoning used
in various ways I describe this um
what's it called a exclusionary on parts
of your parts of your deed covenants
Thank You racial covenants and I've been
collecting them across the United States
that was used in many suburbs many
suburbs in fact required racial
covenants before allowing a subdivision
or a developer to to submit an area for
inclusion in the city so if an entire
city gets covered by exclusionary
covenants then it gets on my radar
screen I'm not interested in communities
that merely keep out blacks from bunches
of neighborhoods I'm only interested in
towns that exclude blacks or others
totally and I assert that there's at
least 10,000 such communities in the
United States I want to give you an
example of other ways it's maintained it
being this all-white nature of
communities this is just one typical
example it's actually less violent than
most but it's so well written and this
was written to me in an email a couple
of years ago but the original event
happened in 1978 in Arcola Arcola is
another small town in Illinois near also
near Champaign Urbana and then in 1978
my correspondent was in seventh grade
okay and she had learned you know
everybody knows everything in small
towns she had learned that there was a
new family moving in that had two small
kids
this news excited me new babysitting
opportunities remember she's in seventh
grade okay
later in the week I was in the school
office this is the k12 school when I saw
a black woman at the Secretary's desk
she looked angry I overheard that her
children could not get registered for
school until all their records got
transferred
I also heard overheard lots of
conversation regarding not knowing what
happened to the records and blaming the
mails etc it didn't dawn on me what was
happening and dawned on me either and
reading this I hope you're have to
faster than I am it didn't dawn on me
what was happening until a few days
later after school at my grandfather's
shop her grandfather ran the auto body
shop in
which was located across the side alley
from the by right grocery store that's
the main supermarket in Arcola the same
woman I had seen in the office at school
pulled up to the by bite and got out of
her car with her two kids she went to
the front door and there was a closed
sign on it and the doors were locked
she looked around as I did because the
parking lot was full people inside
looked to be shopping
I met her gaze and in a brief incident I
had an epiphany
the lightbulb was so bright I thought I
was blinded I was so angry I took her
across the alley and she met my grandpa
they talked in hushed tones while I
played with the kids I overheard them
talking about where she could get some
things he offered her gas see there's an
issue who's going to sell her gas but he
had an aboveground his own above-ground
tank since he was a auto body shop and
he gave her the names and locations of
some Amish friends of his in the rural
that could supply her with milk eggs
meat etc they were there one day and
then a couple of weeks later they were
gone I don't blame them for leaving in
the middle of the night business loaded
my grandfather's shop for a while just
because she did that and he did that
okay but it picked back up with the time
he picked back up with time he was the
only auto body shop in town why haven't
I heard of this before why haven't you
heard of this before
well first of all it is the first book
on the topic I think that's astounding I
want to compare just for a minute with
lynchings okay I would assert that there
are and there have been in the history
of the United States about 10,000
lynchings how do I get that number
well the main lynching database has in
it about 4,600 lynchings but it misses a
lot of them all right so I think it
misses about half of them I mean there's
something like 10,000 and I'm just
saying something like and there's
something like 10,000 sundown towns okay
there have been at more than 500 books
written on lynchings either on a
specific lynching though on the
phenomenon as a whole there are several
hundred in the Library of Congress there
are several hundred for sale right now
in huge listings like amazon.com
which otherwise go on mentioned here
more than 500 books on lynchings and
this is the first book on Sunday on
towns why is that I think there's a
reason for that and I think the reason
in part is success that is we've stopped
lynching have we not now you might argue
well what about that dragging death in
Jasper Texas for instance well what
about it that was no lynching a lynching
you know is a public murder that's the
defining characteristic of it done with
substantial support from the community
this lynching in this murder in Jasper
Texas you know when those three white
folks dragged this guy behind their
pickup them this was a private matter
done on a minor road late at night and
as soon as the community as a whole
found out about it they brought the
three people to justice they executed
two of them and gave one of them life in
prison this is not exactly with support
of the community I just stepped up to
the plate did what it should have done
lynchings have basically ended in
America sure we have all kinds of hate
crimes including hate murders but we do
not have lynchings in that sense it's a
success story I came to this can talk
about it it's a success story I came to
this conclusion when I was writing and
thinking later about lies my teacher
told me because I note for instance that
textbooks written in America in the
1960s and 70s did a terrible job
handling the incarceration of Japanese
Americans during World War two
but now they do a much better job why
because during the George HW Bush
administration remember that one we
actually apologized for the
incarceration gave each survivor $20,000
in indemnity seguir so in that sense
it's a success story I mean we did the
right thing took us a long time aren't
we
etc but now we can talk about it freely
some downtowns we still have many many
communities many rich subs white suburbs
and many independent towns I still Sun
down as we speak okay so it's not a
success story so it's harder to face um
what difference does it make well I want
to just suggest a couple of differences
number one white folks growing up in
some downtown's are likely to grow up
more racist maybe this is obvious to you
certainly is to me
not all of them there are some wonderful
success stories the most famous college
basketball coach probably is John Wooden
for instance at UCLA and he seemed to do
done fine with black folks like Kareem
abdul-jabbar you know and he grew up in
a horrendous Sun downtown Martinsville
Indiana he got over it
all right it's possible but it's not so
easy because one of the things a Sun
downtown or Sunday on suburb is telling
you as you grow up is we're all white on
purpose and we think this is a good
place to grow up and this is good for
you
well why would that be that there's only
one corollary possible right black folks
are bad for you they're an evil people
we have to be separate from them you
have to climb over that and it's not so
easy so it's bad for white folks to grow
up in sundown towns I suggest it's not
good for anybody and it's bad for black
folks to know that there are some
downtown's
not that we should hide the fact we
should get rid of him all right it's
also hard on the on the SIRT the city as
a system it around here for instance
it's hard for a community like Brentwood
now Brentwood Maryland was a Sun
downtown until about 1971 so was
Mountain mania so was University Park
for instance it's hard for towns like
Brentwood and not venir to become and
remain stable and you're the racial now
both of these communities are about
50/50 black white right now increasingly
Latino and so and then they are stable
and interracial but it's tough why
because white folks who gain more money
and more money and more money and we all
want to do that right and more status
tend to want to move to more prestigious
suburbs it's a way of expressing your
money so they maybe want to move to a
Chevy Chase Chevy Chase is four
different suburbs all of which were
sundown towns all of which were created
to be specifically all-white and which
are pretty much sundown towns as we
speak in the year 2000 all four
communities together had I think 17 or
maybe 19 a black well 19 adults in
families that had at least one black
adult okay they didn't have 19 black
adults but they had somewhere between
maybe 8 and 19 black adults in all of
these communities combined you see what
I mean it's hard
so in Illinois for instance it's hard
for Oak Park which is famously
integrated it was a Sun downtown until
about 1950 but now it's integrated and
famously integrated but it's hard to
keep integrated because the white folks
in Oak Park and elsewhere in the Chicago
metropolitan community as they get
richer they want to move to the very
best community and that's maybe
Kenilworth and Kenilworth was created as
a town it explicitly kept out Jews and
blacks and kind of worth in the 2000
didn't have one single black family okay
so it's not a good thing for the social
system either so what should we do about
it well I would suggest first of all we
should be outraged all right and second
of all there's some things that the last
chapter is a bunch of remedies I think
there's things you can do individually
oh if you're black white or other and I
submit most of you in this room or one
of those three um
there's things you can do individually
and and I suggest some of them in the
book I'll suggest one here we can all
work for our state governments or the
federal government even in its current
state of indifference to racial issues
or we can work for it to pass a
residents Rights Act and I described
what that is in the book it's kind of
modeled after the Voting Rights Act real
quickly if a community has a sundown
history and this is provable and I think
I've proven it for a bunch of them and
you can prove it for others if a
community has a sundown history second
if it still has sundown geography like
Chevy Chase does or like Kenilworth does
or like Anna Illinois does Ovilla Grove
and it's and then it has one third
characteristic namely there's been at
least two complaints in the last couple
of years from black folks who have tried
to buy a house in the or met a house in
the community and then rebuffed or had a
difficult time then the residence Rights
Act would kick in and one of its
provisions would be houses in that
community families in that community
would lose their exemption on their
income tax for mortgage interest now of
course one of the best reasons to buy a
house is because most of their house
payments in the early years you know or
mortgage interest and you get to take
that off your income tax
or you can't take rent off but you can
take off interest well as soon and
there's a reason for this
besides the there's a legitimate reason
for this and that is the United States
and for that matter states because they
follow the same rule I want to encourage
homeownership and I think that's good
but do we want to encourage
homeownership by whites in all white
sundown towns surely not
so let's remove that exemption as soon
as we do every single homeowner in the
community is going to want it the
community to recruit black folks please
let's integrate you know so we can get
back our exemption this is one of the
few civil rights acts
that's not only free it's actually
revenue enhancing okay well there's
other ideas about what to do as a remedy
I want to conclude by asserting that one
of the reasons neither you know I have
heard about this until recently is
because that the story has been
suppressed and I just want to give you
two quick examples I mentioned you Ana
they lead review in the Washington Post
this morning is about my book and it
leads off with this conversation I had
and my book leads off for the
conversation I had in Ana in 2002 I
think it was where I confirmed Ana as a
sundown town the first 10 seconds I was
there I stopped at a convenience store
for coffee I asked the clerk is it true
that Ana stands for a n/a ain't no
[ __ ] allowed and she says yes that's
a shame isn't it and the rest of the
conversation I repeat in the beginning
first page of the book okay everybody
knows this about Ana
so in 1954 Ana published a four hundred
and fifty page history of itself called
of course Anna Illinois a century of
progress okay
1954 that's interesting mirror for race
relations isn't it do you think that
this book is so fat and so full that it
has a paragraph or two about every
single business in town there's a
paragraph about the local dairy queen do
you think there's one word about the
expulsion of blacks in 1909 one word
about the lynching one word about the
policy one word about what a nna stands
for nothing
so you have to do this research by oral
history it's suppressed on the whole
from the written record and even orally
you can have problems and so I want to
close with this story from Villa Grove I
had spent the next Monday in Villa Grove
Illinois talking with all kinds of folks
that would be one of them confirmed it
was a sundown town and seven who whom
confirmed the story about the whistle
and its original purpose the last
interview of the day I dropped in at the
weekly newspaper a classic office a
classic newspaper right out of 1890 that
is it's a long story
kind of like kind of like this bookstore
longer and skinnier and there's a
counter in the front and then there's
the editor's desk and there's secretary
over here and there's some more stuff in
the middle and then at the back there's
the printing press it's all right there
okay and I stepped up to the counter and
I introduced myself to the editor I said
hi I'm Jim Lowen
I'm from over here in Decatur blah blah
blah and I'm writing this book about all
white towns that are all white on
purpose such as this one now normally I
didn't do that normally I would try to
extract from him confirmation I'd
already confirmed with eleven different
people that Villa Grove is a Sun
downtown so I didn't need to do that it
was 4:30 I wanted to go back to the
University of Illinois where I was
spending the evening as a guest lecturer
he nodded and said yes I said I then
said quote I understand you have or had
until recently a whistle on your water
tower that sounded at 6:00 p.m. and he
said yes and I said tell me the story
about that whistle and he said quote I
don't know any story about that whistle
unquote well I had met one man
previously that day who didn't know the
story about that whistle so I thought
that was possible I didn't think was
very likely you know the editor of the
newspaper but what am I going to do
shake him and say yes you do
oh so I said well ok well thank you very
much
and at this point the secretary sitting
right over here piped up and she said
you mean the story that that whistle
sounded at 6:00 p.m. to tell African
Americans to be out of town and I said
yes that story and she said I never
heard that story
you'll figure it out
that's the phenomenon of my book and the
reason I think it's so important is I
think I want you to buy it and I want
you to read it and keep it nice and I'll
just sign it blank I'll send it to you
if you want that I just sign it blank
and you keep it nice and then you give
it to somebody who needs it
ok somebody who lives in one of these
communities or somebody who will do
something about it or hopefully you will
and then you pass it on to somebody else
and somebody else in somebody else
because this is an ongoing shame in our
nation it's still going on right now
across the North we've got a without it
know about it the first way to change it
is to out it because these communities
want to be exclusive but they don't want
to be seen as excluding because that's
kind of lower-class right so we need to
out them and change them thank you very
much for your attention now I'd love to
take a couple of questions maybe even
more than a couple but you have to use
the microphone so that your question
goes out to the ether there was a study
did about hood a couple of years ago and
it concluded that Freddie Mae and
Freddie Mac had engaged in racial
discrimination their policy for lending
I think was a 40 percent under the norm
for blacks something like 15 percent for
Hispanics and 30 percent three percent
over the NAM for Asians and then in in
1934 the federal housing authority that
insures loans at one time it was
characterized as instituting policy that
may have been curved from the Nuremburg
but to what extent does these lending
institutions and the Federal Housing
Association exacerbate you know these
kind of closed communities good question
yeah it's it's shocking to realize that
actually having sundown towns has been
illegal since 1917 in fact in a sense it
was always illegal if you read the 14th
amendment
you know which guarantees black folks
right to make contract without regard to
race for instance and that includes the
right to make housing contracts but
there's but there was a Supreme Court
decision right in the middle of the
Nader period this terrible period there
was nevertheless one positive Supreme
Court decision about race I think the
only one and it's called Buchanan V
Worley and it came out in nineteen
seventeen and what it was against these
ordinances called residential
segregation ordinances which had been
passed it was the thing to do and they
were passed by major southern cities and
even non southern cities as far
northeast Baltimore in Louisville and
st. Louis New Orleans and so on and what
these ordinances said was okay if we
have a white block or a majority white
block nobody black can buy a house on
that block we won't move out the black
folks had already happen to be living on
it if it's a majority white block but
nobody knew who's black can buy a house
on that block and same thing if we have
a black block nobody white can buy a
house on that block okay so it's
even-handed right like Plessy vs.
Ferguson well of course it was only
enforced against blacks who wanted to
move into white box it would immediately
or fairly soon turn every city and to
complete apartheid if you think about it
because fairly soon almost every house
gets sold you know some houses stay in
the family for generations about most
houses people move people die and so on
they get sold um why was this decision
made in 1917 well it turns out the
Supreme Court found that a white right
was being violated I don't think it
would have done anything of a black
right a mere black right had been
violated in 1917 in the middle of the
Nader but a white right was violated how
so well let's suppose you own a house
that's worth a hundred thousand dollars
of course back then it would be a lot
less but let's say in today's more well
in today's market in DC be six hundred
thousand but anyway let's say you're on
a house that's a hundred thousand
dollars okay in the white neighborhood
okay and you want to sell it and you're
getting offer four hundred thousand
dollars from a white person naturally
but some black person who wants to
escape the ghetto or who wants to live
on this block or for whatever reason
wants to buy this house and is willing
to pay you one hundred and ten thousand
dollars but you can't sell to him or her
because of this ordinance so you've lost
ten thousand dollars right haven't you
no haven't you and so see a white right
the right of dispersion
of your property as best you see fit
that's a white light you've lost it so
the Supreme Court said that's illegal
all right well if you just follow that
reasoning there's no doubt that sundown
ordinances which town after town was
passing in the north and they're
one-sided they didn't have any two sides
about them would have been found illegal
but they were never enforced this
decision was never enforced and even
worse the federal government completely
ignored this decision by the United
States Supreme Court so we find that
during the FDR administration seven at
least different towns were invented by
the federal government including
Greenbelt Maryland not far from here and
all of them were invented as sundown
towns blacks were not allowed after dark
there's three different greens there's a
Greenbelt type town outside Cincinnati
and another one outside Milwaukee
there's Boulder Nevada which was
invented for people who built Hoover Dam
black folks helped build Hoover Dam but
they had to commute the boulder was a
Sun downtown Richland
I think it's Richland Washington the
town that built the one of the two atom
bombs that was a Sun downtown invented
by the federal government and then the
FHA chimes in during the Depression and
until 1968 really and the FHA made a
policy of never loaning to an individual
neighborhood or an interracial community
and in fact in the book there's actually
a photo of this it's hard to make
policies visible but in Detroit in
Northwest Detroit you can see this on
the ground there's an amazing wall and
the pictures in the book that was put up
and maybe 1950 or so a developer in
Northwest Detroit wanted to get FHA
guarantees for the home loan so that he
could sell make and sell houses but it
was in an interracial neighborhood but
although black folks in this interracial
neighborhood lived toward the east the
eastern part was interracial the western
part of the neighborhood it was really
one neighborhood was all white FHA
wouldn't touch it so he put up this wall
that goes from 8 mile the famous
northern boundary of Detroit you've
maybe seen the movie 8 mile which has
some actual accurate race relations in
it it's a fine work of sociology um this
wall goes from 8 mile down to a big park
it doesn't go across the streets but it
goes block to block to block it's about
this high made out of concrete blocks
faced with concrete it still stands
neighborhood kids have put graffiti on
it and made little murals on it black
folks now live on both sides of it but
see this segregated the neighborhood so
that the the western half of it was all
white now the FHA would loan to the
western half so yeah the FHA was a big
part of the problem the federal
government was a big part of the problem
a huge part of the problem and it makes
a huge difference because suburbia
seemed suburb 80% at least of all
suburbs in America were built in sundown
towns with the support of the federal
government and that was largely after
World War two and one of the differences
it makes right now some of you may be
read about the wealth gap you know black
folks make about 70 percent as much
income as white folks maybe even a
higher percentage of that if you do a
couple of qualifications for education
and marital status but there's a huge
wealth gap it's about 1 to 11 that is
the amount of wealth that the typical
black family has is 111th as much as the
amount of wealth that a typical white
family has where is the bulk of any
family's wealth their home equity okay
over the generations when did it
especially happen after World War two
when we and I speak racially here we got
support for building our and buying our
home in suburbia Levittown all of the
Levittown's were sundown towns most of
the development by the lebanon company
which built 8% of suburbia all by itself
most of that development kept out Jews
as well even though Levitt was Jewish
better business of all of these
communities then you got a house for
maybe ten thousand dollars that is now
worth $200,000 and that's where much of
our equity our equity and I again speak
racially comes from and blacks could
just flatly shut out of that so as a
problem to the present no more questions
come on your people here's one
this is less of question as saying when
people wonder well what can we do about
it it's my understanding that the Urban
League has a couple of decades after I
moved into Sheppard Park across on the
other side of the park which itself is a
racial barrier Rock Creek the they take
you know a couple who other than being
african-american versus white I'll have
the exact same credentials and
everything and it's you know and then
they'll go out yeah it's gone testing
yeah and I they're still do I think
they're still doing it and if anybody
wants to help across the nation not just
here in the Washington area talking to
somebody in the Urban League and getting
the more local getting local chapters to
do some of this stuff might get a fire
set not literally you know to to do away
with it good point thanks for that point
okay we're just going to take two more
questions the two that are standing up
already yes sir hi I'm I'm a teacher in
the area but uh both of your books
already enjoy them I wanted to know what
advice you could give me as a teacher in
terms of having students do the critical
research that is necessary so that they
don't buy it face value some of the
things and things that question in
textbooks and in in other things that
they're being taught whether it be math
history English I think they need to be
taught the skill to question and I want
to know how they should further develop
their own skills as a researcher so I
sure do it for them let me give you just
two ideas the first will be in general
and second one will be about sundown
towns the idea in general especially in
history or social studies have more than
one textbook in the room so that the
idea can't be to learn the right answer
that's in the textbook because of course
textbooks don't teach the right answer
some of them in fact teach
systematically the wrong answer as I
found out in lies my teacher told me but
as soon as you have different books in
a phenomenon occurs there's a teacher
writing in Washington DC who does this
she has a plastic rectangular bushel
basket full of old textbooks in the
corner of her room she teaches 11th
grade US history and these are old
textbook schism from 1924 to the present
and at Sheep
I mean it's not an expensive thing to do
many used bookstores won't even handle
them because nobody wants old textbooks
when you find one that does sell them
they're $0.50 so it's no great
investment she's got about 30 of them
over there in the in the box and when
things go gets low she says she says to
the students or sometimes she does it on
purpose she does it for President Hoover
for instance okay everybody go get a
book and so they all go and they know
this means go get a book from the from
the bushel basket over there so they all
get their book some of them get the same
book every time others just get whatever
book they get and they learn about
Hoover and Don if they don't learn that
one learns maybe that President Hoover
was very concerned about people's rights
he cared cared about the depression he
had been in charge of relief in Europe
after World War one after all he had
been in charge of relief in Mississippi
in Louisiana after the devastating 1927
flood kind of the precursor of our
Katrina disaster so he cared about poor
people he didn't know what to do about
the depression but he could but another
person from their textbook learns that
President Hoover was a millionaire a
self-made millionaire he thought anybody
could become wealthy in America if they
just were good enough and that poor
people didn't try hard enough
and another person learns that he did
care but he was hamstrung by his
Republican small government ideology was
another person and you suddenly realize
it makes no sense to learn what the
textbook says because her textbook says
something different from his textbooks
there's something different from that
one so then you have to think you know
that's one idea and the other idea about
sundown towns students even middle
school students and serving high school
students can do research on the racial
history of their community especially if
it was a sundown town and some of them
have across the country having gotten
the idea for me if I'm my speaking and
now hopefully they'll get it from the
book they can go interview both folks
for instance middle school students are
really good at
they can go to a nursing home yep - tape
recorder on have wonderful conversations
with 80 year olds who often know a lot
better about the 1930s than they do
about what happened last week as a
matter of fact I know more about the
1930s increasingly than I do what
happened last week um and so they can
they can help out these communities by
doing good research on them and really
improving and some towns are no longer
sundown towns and that's a great story -
we need to learn how did that happen how
did Oak Park desegregate how did
Valparaiso Indiana which was famous for
being all white community with
Valparaiso University and so on and in
that case actually two black families
from Chicago were recruited in and
brought in and the white professors and
students from the University who brought
them and had to maintain a 24-hour guard
on the house because people threatened
them and so on but it worked and
Valparaiso is now over it you know these
are wonderful stories worth telling and
students can be involved in the telling
and last question it better be good are
you ready I'm ready
well it's obvious that race relations in
this country is still unfinished
business your book makes the case quite
well Hurricane Katrina showed that to us
so my question to you is given what you
were saying about black families being
driven out of town and not knowing if
they were compensated for their homes
and also the the knowing disparity
between the families wealth and this
racial policy about housing did the
issue of reparations come up for you
while you are doing your research
definitely um I think that the idea of
reparations for our son downtown
policies and for the entire policies we
did during the Nader let's say from 1890
to 1968 because that's when the federal
government switched sides and there's
some communities that have yet to switch
sides I think the the idea of
reparations is definitely involved and
we've actually paid it once and that is
for the Sundown town of Rosewood Florida
now Rose would rather famously drove out
its black population in one 1922 I'm a
sociologist we just try to get it
approved
approximate you know I'm within two
years I think and the state of Florida
about four or five years ago paid
reparations for that now any such
expulsion like the explosion from Vienna
Illinois in nineteen fifty four is a
breakdown of law and order it's a
breakdown of the government among other
things because the government is
required one of its primary purpose is
to make us secure in our own homes you
know to make us in a secure peaceful
community and usually of course we find
in such a situation that the government
is overtly on the opposite side but at
the very least it fails to provide
security in the home security and so the
government is part of the liability
Network as well as the specific white
people who did the the driving out and
that's what Florida stepped up to the
plate and dealt with now Tulsa failed to
deal with it about a year or two ago and
may yet deal with it we hope it will um
there's a movement in Tulsa to pay
reparations and in Oklahoma but so far
it has not passed the legislature it
should um there has been no movement in
any of the other sundown towns that I
know of I have to say this this last
summer an African American who is the
descendant of a family in Pierce City
Missouri found out about how his family
and how the entire black community was
expelled from Pierce City and this past
summer got his great-grandfather's
remains exhumed from the Pierce city
cemetery and reburied in Springfield
Missouri because of course there's
nobody to keep up the grave or visit the
grave or anything else in Pierce city
the family's cemetery plot is in
Springfield having left there over a
century ago and he got Pierce City to
officially apologize for the expulsion
but I don't even know of any other I
don't think I know I might know of one
other but it doesn't come to mind right
now of them of the thousands of sundown
towns I don't think any of them have
even apologized I think at the very
least we should expect sundown towns to
do three things
state they did it admit it we did this
that's a problem already to get them to
do that number two apologize we did it
and it was wrong and number three
admit and not in young knit but stayed
openly we don't do it anymore we welcome
everybody
after all George Wallace did those three
things before he died
can't we get Chevy Chase to do that
can't we get University Park etc to do
that I think I think we should and then
the question of reparations is perfectly
reasonable especially I think about like
Vienna Illinois there's plenty of people
alive today
I mean least several this having
happened in nineteen fifty four who were
personally driven out of Vienna you know
what about them okay I think you've got
a good point there well come up and ask
me more stuff I'll be up here signing
books oh I will show you my map if you
wish this is my beaten up Road atlas I
will show you